foreign
[Music]
we have called out to the universe
looking for answers
in 2024
the universe
calls back
bring us your lead
[Music]
hi can you hear me honey now is a really
bad time okay
bye I love you I love you I love you
this is new
[Music]
whoa please State the name of your
Homeworld uh Earth welcome leader of
Earth
we are the United Advanced species of
the Universe I think there's been a
mistake you're not the leader of all
Earth sorry for the mix-up commence
memory wise no wait
I am the leader of Earth why is your
voice different uh I've always talked
like this since I was a kid which I'm
obviously not anymore but yes I run the
planet the trial of Earth can proceed uh
oh until then as you say on Earth okay
bye I love you okay okay bye
if Mom could see me now I know what you
mean I ate my mother at Birth but in
moments of great success I regret it
that's a thing for your species no just
a me thing everyone was shocked
[Music]
laughs